so you were rebellious as a young you
know just punk straight oh right
like what kind of punk did you listen to
you know bad brains and crowmags and
madball hardcore
mostly hardcore yeah you know yeah to be
honest
not too punk because i got into music
through metal
oh you liked metal i was a metal i was a
young metal head i was a very young
metal head into like deicide and
obituary and
yeah that kind of stuff i just kind of
liked um
it's just older stuff i guess not really
necessarily punk but i was like
kind of more into like the clash even
before that like maybe like
the thugs or bugs you remember the thugs
no
like a new york kind of like before
there was like you know uh
stooges low-fat very low-five music
nice i like the stooges a lot i like
development underground yeah like that
but heroin music i liked heroin music
yeah i really did heroin music's good
yeah and um i also liked um sad core
before it was sad core oh
you know i mean i like listening to
music and wanting to kill myself
yeah did you really no i've always i
don't have that
oh no i like demo yeah did you never
want to kill yourself
uh not intentionally yeah i think i'm a
happy spirit i don't have too many
demons i was just like a joy boy
who wanted to get [ __ ] up and like
smash everything yeah
did you um did you oh do you like women
i mean you're married right yeah you
ever experiment
with both sides i'm pansexual are you
really
uh i don't know i think when i was high
and drunk
yeah yeah for sure yeah when i get drunk
if i could do a key bump with you i'd
french kiss you yeah yeah you know when
i get drunk i get a little wild i'll be
honest yeah
i don't drink yeah but i've been with
the same woman for 20 years
yeah we went to prom together
[Music]
she's cute she was god she was like the
one hot goth check
her whole family she's like the youngest
of like what four or four goths
so we used to call them a craft yeah
it was just like a small town [ __ ] her
whole family was like the gothic girls
yeah wait i think she was canadian too
fair za balk from the craft right really
maybe wasn't she gilbert gilbert get on
george what's wrong with you gilbert has
no i'll be honest i'm looking at
photos of your beautiful family i was
like yeah look at your children oh yeah
google image me there we go
endless amounts i've i've put my entire
life on the internet
yeah yeah squishy there she is look at
her
so um you started cooking at uh
when you're 20ish yeah and then i
dropped out of college
and then you know and then i dropped out
of college
and then yeah and then i like toured
around with like some metal bands and
punk bands and stuff yeah have fun and
then
and then um you know i come from a
working class family so i didn't have
like
money so then i had to get a job
then i got a job when he used to have to
hand out resumes
and then i used to hand out a lot of
resumes and then
uh the best i got a job at like the best
bistro in toronto
and then i was working there and that's
how it happened and then yeah that was
like i went in there and i was like oh
this is like a real thing this is like
school
everyone's wearing chef whites and
there's a chef and it's very intense
and yeah and then i uh i liked it and i
was good at it
and then i built up like self-esteem i
think a little bit
self-esteem because i was good at
something but i bet your money though
that you
i also loved it i loved it it was it was
very similar to uh
being like with my friends bands and
being on the road and being in a van
it's
tight-knit it's very intense it's long
hours
that's the thing it's i think that you
know the thing that one needs to find
is a thing that they love to do right
because i was addicted to even when i
was a young guy
to just going up in random places and
doing stand-up you know and the
adrenaline of it
and that was the first time where i felt
kind of like alive you know
not that you think that you're gonna
like make it really
you're just like i found a thing you
found
you finally found a place that you
belonged yeah and that you
respected and you were like if i give
something i get something back from it
yeah the reciprocal yeah there was this
man by the name of fred burns who was
the general manager of the comedy store
in the 90s
and he was um had spinal bifida so you'd
have to carry him around
and he was a drunk as well and me and my
friend jonathan godzik
he used to go come over because we used
to like make him like omelets
not me but jonathan would and like and
he was like
get drunk in the morning and in this
small little tiny apartment
he lived with all these two other
comedians and he would tell these wild
stand-up stories and i remember me and
jonathan because we were in our 20s
yeah and just sitting around like kind
of like not in a campfire but it felt
like that